Apple's Mac safe wireless charging
feature has quickly taken over the world
so much so that Android phones will be
getting Qi 2.0 Max safe later this year
but the truth is Apple has an even
bigger master plan for a Max safe which
will begin to be revealed at Apple's
WWDC event in less than two weeks so in
this video I'm going to talk about Mark
German's major new iPhone feature leak
that Apple plans to bring on with iOS 17
as well as how the iPhone 15 will take
Max safe to a whole new level first off
we've got to talk about iOS 17 and how
Apple envisions users to take advantage
of maxsafe in a really unique way
according to Mark German the major new
feature of iOS 17 will actually be a new
lock screen interface that'll literally
turn your iPhone into a smart home
display just imagine being able to
conveniently control all of your smart
home lights blinds speakers cameras and
more right from your iPhone at any time
of the night or in the morning
apparently the way to enable it is to
have your iPhone be not in use while
positioned in a horizontal orientation
with the best example being the scenario
where you attach your iPhone to a Max
safe charging stand at night enabling
the new mode instantly the background
will become dark and the text will be
light so that it's easy to read and use
then a bunch of information will pop up
including calendar appointments weather
data notifications and more basically
turning it into a home data Hub the goal
of this is to basically make your iPhone
more useful when not in use and honestly
that's a great idea because right now
you don't have access to any smart
devices or much interesting data or
controls when the lock screen is enabled
so it looks like Max save is going to be
at the center of this new feature
encouraging more and more people to
switch to macsafe stands in order to use
it but before I get into how the iPhone
15 will take macsafe to the next level
later this year I've got to talk about a
couple of other interesting iOS 17
features that are coming at WWDC but
first I've got to give a shout out to
our partner case Q for their magic stand
case which is the best value case you
can get since it's very rugged high
quality and stylish while also featuring
magnets for all of your Mac safe
accessories but making it even better
the maxafe ring is actually on a hinge
that works as a finger grip and a stand
at a variety of different angles for
things like watching videos or even
taking photos so go ahead and check out
the discount info and the link down in
the description below now getting back
to iOS 17 one thing that we should
expect is more customizable options for
Widgets or basically turning them into
interactive widgets with more controls
which right now it is extremely limited
and I think this new change is going to
be part of that smart home display
feature and there's just so many other
things that will be more useful when we
get those interactive widgets with iOS
17. Mark German also said that iOS 17 is
going to feature a bunch of huge changes
and updates to a lot of the apps like
the wallet app find my changes better
share Play features when sharing content
like when doing FaceTime and you're also
going to have AirPlay upgrades as well
so across the board a lot of the things
are getting upgraded but now let's move
on to how the iPhone 15 will take maxafe
to the next level we recently got a
brand new report from a Korean blogger
named ux1122 sorry I butcher that but
the iPhone 15 is gonna support 15 watt
Max safe wireless charging while using
third-party Chargers that are not Mac
safe certified that is absolutely huge
because right now there are so many
unique Mac safe accessories out there
but they're all limited to 7.5 watt
charging because of Apple's artificial
limitation which is basically just
making sure that it can detect Apple's
own maxsafe unit using NFC and then it
allows 15 watt wireless charging if not
you only get half of that which is
ridiculous for example right now my
favorite Mac type accessory is my car
charger that plugs into my vent mount
Wireless charges it at the same time but
it's only 7.5 Watts because it's not
certified but I use it because I like it
better than all of the other Apple
expense of options out there those ones
aren't great they're very very pricey so
the big question is why is Apple going
to allow the full 15 watts with
third-party Max save Chargers well this
basically proves that the new G2
wireless charging standard is likely
going to support 15 watt charging at a
minimum for all of the Android phones so
with that said it basically doesn't make
sense for Apple to keep this 7.5 watt
limit while all the Android folks are
getting 15 watts it would be
embarrassing to be an iPhone user so I
think that's why they're giving all
iPhone 15s and up the full 15 watts
however the big problem here is this how
will Apple continue to make Max safe
certification special on the iPhone 15
if you can simply get 15 watt charging
with any third-party charger well we had
a leak that the new iPhone 15 models
will support 20 watt Max save charging
but only with a certified Max safe
charger not any third party and then
this way people who want to pay for the
fastest charging will continue to buy
the more expensive Apple Mac safe
Chargers and this is likely going to
happen thanks to more efficient charging
coils maybe more efficient chips like
the a17 and other factors that lead to
less heat overall now we've also been
getting rumors that apple is planning to
bring more reverse wireless charging
features to more accessories and devices
and I fully believe that starting with
the iPhone 15 it's going to support
reverse wireless charging for airpods
especially since now the airpods Pro 2
support Max safe charging so it's
basically a no-brainer for Apple to
allow you to charge your airpods from
your iPhone so now in conclusion I want
to finish off with my purse personal
prediction of how all of this Max safe
master plan stuff is going to play out
over the future first of all I believe
that the Apple car is going to be loaded
with Apple Mac safe pucks or Chargers in
the car itself and then I believe
further on into the future even more car
brands are actually going to have Max
safe wireless chargers and then on top
of that I think Max save is going to
gain data transfer using a new cable and
then that's when the portless iPhone
will emerge relying on Max safe but
apple is going to require an mfi Max
save cable for the data transfer aspect
and to back up your iPhone that's how
they're gonna still make money with Max
safe and then I even believe that
portless Android phones will require G2
as well completely ditching USBC later
on in the future and then of course
we're gonna get even more and more
unique macsafe accessories for the time
to come so there you go that's my
thoughts on WWDC and iOS 17 later this
year in just a couple of weeks and the
iPhone 15 and all those features so let
me know what you like down in the
comment section below and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign